early Sunday morning on Columbus Avenue  in downtown Senate so he's just going  through downtown  where San Dustin Sandusky it's time they  changed that name you can change the  name team obtained dash camera video of  the man so we'll show this okay okay the  officer pulled the vehicle over and  charged both the driver and the man with  a minor misdemeanor of riding outside  the vehicle I didn't know that was a  misdemean right into that vehicle  Tom Cruise does it all the time I just  want to say that begins to work we have  not heard if it's some kind of a tick  tock challenge or Internet dalgan said  Raleigh is some kind of tick tock  challenge blame the Chinese yeah why do  you sort of dank meme this is the point  in the article which I love the guy on  the card so much shortly after the  officer pulled the vehicle over he asked  the man if there was any reason why he  was on the roof the man said no  God bless him